le
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat et cette semaine avec steve
jourdain nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir bernard jomier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur de paris
membre du groupe socialiste écologistes
et républicains ici au sénat etc stif
qui brosse de votre parti bernard je me
vous avez 57 ans vous êtes né à clermont
ferrand vous êtes médecin généraliste de
profession spécialiste en médecine
tropicale c'est pourtant dans une ville
pas vraiment réputé pour son climat
tropical que vous allez poser vos
valises vous avez choisi paris pour vous
installer en politique en 2001 vous êtes
élu maire-adjoint du 19e arrondissement
vous avez aussi été adjoint d'anne
hidalgo en charge de la santé et du
handicap vous êtes sénateur de paris
depuis 2010 est dans l'art juillet vous
êtes un homme politique mais vous n'avez
jamais abandonné la médecine première
vague de l'épidémie vous êtes engagés
dans la réserve sanitaire vous avez
repris du service à l'hôpital questions
simples la deuxième vague
et là vous allez vous engager à nouveau
en tout cas moi j'ai dit aux services
auxquels j'avais été affecté à l'hôpital
de melun que je serai évidemment
disponible s'il avait besoin de moi et
en attendant je continue et j'irai cet
après midi à mon cabinet fermé
consultation comme toutes les semaines
est ce qu'il ya une crainte aujourd'hui
que les médecins les infirmières
n'arrive pas à tenir le coup sur cette
deuxième vague on parle beaucoup de
démission par exemple d'un corps médical
ils démissionneront pas pendant la vague
mais ce qui est très inquiétant c'est
que après la première vague du printemps
le mouvement de départ des soignants de
l'hôpital ce qui s'est arrêté pendant la
vague a repris et l'a repris de façon
importante on n'a pas su les retenir les
mesures suffisantes n'ont pas été prises
et donc on arrive à cette deuxième vague
dans un état beaucoup moins bons que
pour la première vague et quoi qu'en
dise le ministre nous n'avons pas douze
mille lits de réanimation
en france c'est y joue sur les mots on à
l'élysée on a le matériel etc
on n'a pas les personnels donc ça va
être extrêmement difficile mais moi je
les connais bien et je sais ce que ces
aides soignants on ne déserte pas quand
quand la crise est là on va bien
d'argent mais vous demander votre avis
en tant que médecin mais aussi en tant
que sénateur on passait là tout de suite
au sommaire de cette émission
jean castex le premier ministre devant
les députés pour défendre leur
confinement leur confinement ses solos
louis la seule solution toute l'europe
est frappée par une seconde vague
inattendue par son ampleur des débats
extrêmement passionnées une volonté de
faire respecter les droits du parlement
les sénateurs débattent du projet de loi
de prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ont fait le point dans un
instant mais avant tout cela avant
d'évoquer la situation à sanitaires on
voulait évidemment vous faire réagir à
cet attentat commis à nice jeudi trois
personnes tuées devant la basilique
notre dame
le premier ministre était devant les
députés pour évoquer la situation
sanitaire lorsque l'attaqué s'est
produite
le débat a été interrompu il ya eu une
minute de silence je vous propose de
regarder ces quelques images
voilà un grand moment d'émotion juste
avant le vote le premier ministre a fait
un point sur la situation des coûts de
jean castex
un attentat
a été commis ce matin en la basilique
notre dame à nice aux alentours de 9
heures cette attaque aussi lâche que
barbare endeuillent le pays tout entier
la réponse du gouvernement sera ferme
implacable et immédiate
j'ai d'ores et déjà j'ai d'ores et déjà
décidé de porter le plan vigipirate au
niveau d'urgence attentat sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
bernard genier votre sentiment c'est
l'effroi c'est la colère ou c'est un
sentiment d'impuissance
non d'abord de grande tristesse et
d'impuissance certainement pas mais je
voudrais qu'on essaye de se mettre un
petit peu en perspective les grandes
religions monothéistes où tout sécréter
des individus qui est qui sont passés à
des actes extrêmement violent et si je
dis ça c'est pas pour relativiser mais
c'est parce que l'histoire nous a appris
quelque chose
premièrement c'est que ces individus ne
sont pas déconnectés il ne tombe pas
d'une autre planète
ils sont le produit d'un discours
radical qui s'est développée au fil du
temps et donc il faut agir sur ce
discours radical et sur ceux qui
tiennent ce discours radical et moi je
souscris aux actions qui sont menées
contre ceux notamment qui ont un double
discours qui utilisent la question
sociale qui se masque derrière des
actions humanitaires pour tenir un
discours radical parliez l'association
lo ng baraka city par exemple
deuxièmement ce sont les religions sont
en difficulté à chaque fois pour faire
face à leurs propres extrémistes et donc
les injonction permanente envers la
communauté musulmane ne sont pas opérant
qu'il n'y a pas de problème l'islam en
france comme le nom le h aire marine le
pen il n'y en a pas et je d'ailleurs je
salue la réaction du président du comité
du conseil français du culte musulman
qui appelait symboliquement à fermer les
mosquées à fermer les mosquées en
hommage donc c'est un acte extrêmement
important mais ce que ça veut dire c'est
que la puissance publique doit s'en
mêler
alors la connaissance publique qui n'a
pas vocation à gérer les religions
à doit s'en occuper parce que la
religion musulmane ne peut pas seul
faire face à ses propres ex précisément
qu'est ce qu'on fait christian estrosi
le maire de nice dit qu'il faut je cite
sortir des lois de la paix sortir de
l'état de droit qu'est ce que vous en
pensez et bien et c'est la troisième le
troisième point ça ne peut pas se faire
à n'importe quelle condition et
certainement pas en affaiblissant notre
démocratie et nos valeurs or ce que
propose actuellement christian estrosi
ou d'autres jeux les bien entendu le
rassemblement national c'est de mettre à
bas notait un autre état de droit cette
réponse à l'extrémisme religieux
nous y arriverons mais en respectant
l'état devra et nous avons parce que il
ya quand même des facteurs un peu
d'optimisme il faut le dire
la sécularisation qui est essentiel la
sécularisation d'une religion dans la
société pour faire en sorte qu'elles
s'intègrent elle est beaucoup plus
avancé que ce qu'on pense que ce qu'on
voit ces actes là encore une fois
doivent être combattus et à la racine en
amont je les dis sur les discours
radicaux mais l'immense majorité des
musulmans de france se sécularise le
gouvernement va présenter son projet de
loi sur les séparatismes le 9 décembre
prochain
il faut muscler l'arsenal législatif de
l'état dispose des moyens nécessaires
pour lutter contre cet islamisme radical
nous voyait que le gouvernement a décidé
de passer à l'action dans le cadre de
l'état de droit
il a commencé à procéder à une fée la
fermeture d'une mosquée qui joue un
double jeu la grande mosquée de pantin
avec un imam qui scolariser ses enfants
dans une école coranique interdite donc
tout élevage à poser cible en fait
pourquoi n'at-on pas faible mais
beaucoup est possible beaucoup est
possible dans le cadre actuel et tout
est possible dans le cadre de l'état de
droit et il n'y a pas de nécessité
sans arrêt vous savez cette attitude qui
est qu'à chaque fois qu'il y à un nouvel
événement on se précipite pour voter
noah et que derrière on n'agit pas sur
les questions sociétales sur la question
sociale et cetera sur les vrais héros de
cette dérive radicale san produits ont
pas grand chose en fait trop de
communication ce moment on fait souvent
trop de communication politique on
accuse souvent la gauche le gouvernement
notamment
d'avoir été un peu naïve sur ces
questions certains parlent même d'un
islam au gauchisme qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez je crois pas qu'ils aient
de faiblesse je crois que il ya toujours
une grande réticence des gouvernants à
se mêler de la question religieuse dans
notre pays sert que la notre conception
de la laïcité est très très difficile à
comprendre d'ailleurs les étrangers ne
la comprennent pas du tout et dans notre
propre pays il ya débats incessants
autour de cette question de la laïcité
et donc nos gouvernants hésitent
toujours à se mêler des questions
religieuses parce que tout de suite
l'amalgamé et effet vous êtes contre une
religion
nous n'avons pas été contre la religion
catholique mais nous lui avons dans
notre histoire rappelé qu'elle était à
une place et qu'elle plaidait pas en
charge des affaires publiques
aujourd'hui l'islam ou peut être
pratiquée dans notés d'une façon apaisée
c'est le cas de l'immense majorité mais
il faut être très clair
les pouvoirs publics ont toute
légitimité à lutter contre les discours
radicaux qui se termine en acte
terroriste quelques mots vous l'avez dit
on comprend pas toujours la laïcité à la
française il faut continuer à publier
ces caricatures de mahomet je pense pas
que ce soit l'état de le faire
j'ai vu le projet du ministre de
l'éducation que je ne comprends pas très
bien qui est de fournir des livres de
caricatures il faut défendre sans cesse
le droit de publier ces caricatures mais
ce n'est pas à l'état de délivrer des
caricatures sur telle ou telle religion
et bien je me en passe de la menace
terroriste à la menace sanitaire
[Musique]
et oui après les annonces des manuels
macron mercredi soir le premier ministre
était devant les députés jeudi matin
devant les sénateurs jeudi après midi
leur confinement c'est la seule solution
at il justifié le récit de la journée
avec stéphanie des pierres l'artisan du
déconfinement est devenu l'architecte
dur confinement impossible de faire
autrement
jean castex le martel et il réfute les
accusations d'un préparation face à la
deuxième vague
si nous avons soi-disant raté le
déconfinement en france alors il a été
raté par tous cas partout la réalité est
la même
il n'y a pas qu'en france qu'on ferme
les hôtels les cafés les restaurants les
salles de spectacles partout en europe
partout tout la majorité était derrière
le premier ministre les socialistes
aussi honte a prouvé sa déclaration mais
avec de grandes réserves ce sera un oui
de responsabilité parce que pour nous la
protection de la santé de nos
concitoyens doit être la priorité
absolue
mais notre oui mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues de la
majorité sera également un oui de colère
oui de colère face à votre impréparation
le 26 août
il ya donc deux mois le premier ministre
déclarait sur france inter je le cite
qu'il n'y avait pas de quoi s'affoler à
gauche encore la majorité des
communistes à voter pour les insoumis
eux ont tous dit non tout le monde peut
constater que vous êtes pris de court
surpris a dit le président pourtant il
fanfaronnait en lui ai tout est prêt
vous nous demander un vote de confiance
eh bien nous n'avons pas confiance et
nous avons de moins en moins confiance
autant vous le dire
l'est républicain le plus gros groupes
d'opposition avaient aussi décidé de
dire non mais ils ont changé d'avis
après l'annnonce de l'attentât à nice
ils n'ont pas participé au vote pour ne
pas ajouter des divisions dans le pays
alors le premier ministre est livré au
même exercice au sénat berling juliette
vous avez voté pour
oui oui je veux parce que au stade où on
en est il n'ya pas d'autre choix que
d'appliquer de nouvelles mesures dont le
confinement pour casser l'épidémie
mais comme
a dit valérie rabault à l'assemblée
nationale ce n'est en aucun cas un vote
de confiance au gouvernement c'est un
vote pour les français c'est parce qu'on
doit protéger les français
on doit prendre ces mesures mais il faut
le dire
la sévérité des mesures qui sont prises
c'est l'exact reflet de l'échec de la
politique depuis santé publique menées
en amont et ça n'est pas faute de
l'avoir dit vous êtes co rapporteur de
la commission denquête qu'ovide au sénat
concrètement où est ce que le
gouvernement a échoué sur beaucoup de
points mais en gros on avait deux grands
piliers à notre stratégie la
distanciation physique incluant les
masques et les gestes barrières et là ça
fonctionne plutôt bien et les français
applique très majoritairement m6 a
toujours des exceptions
cette s'être règles là et puis le
deuxième grand pilier c'était la
stratégie testé pour des trouver les
personnes positives tracer les contacts
et isoler les personnes contagieuses et
cette stratégie là elle est totalement
en échec alors le gouvernement il dit
une demi-vérité des demi vérités en
permanence quand il dit oui mais
l'épidémie repart partout en europe
bien sûr on n'a pas éradiqué le virus et
la planification du gouvernement la
france n'est pas seule elle ça je vais
vous dire d'envoi c'est une demi vérité
puis sévère parce que les pays européens
ne sont pas dans une stratégie
d'éradication donc on savait que le
virus circulera et qui re commencerait à
circuler plus fort avec l'automne on
savait tout le monde n'était pas
d'accord sur ce point
sur la deuxième vague alors moi je vais
écarté la toux ceux qui sont dans le
révisionnisme scientifique dans le
complotisme qui pro qui propagent des
nouvelles absolument infondée et qu'ils
feraient mieux de cesser de parler parce
que il porte un tort considérable à
l'ensemble du pays mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que cette épidémie cette
circulation qu'ils allaient reprendre de
nos actions et notamment de la mise en
oeuvre correcte de la stratégie tracée
isolé allait dépendre la pente et c'est
la pente le problème parce que si ça
avait grimpé mais doucement
nos oreilles taux ne serait pas débordé
et c'est l'objectif que nos hôpitaux ne
soit pas débordés là ils vont être
déportés il commence à l'être et ils le
seront fortement dans une dizaine de
jours alors on le voit le gouvernement
met en place un confinement pour quatre
semaines mais un confinement très
différent que celui du printemps par
exemple les écoles
est ouverte les écoles les collèges les
lycées est ce que c'est une bonne
solution ou ne risque-t-on pas des
contaminations de famille avec cette
ouverture le gouvernement arbitre entre
la réduction de la circulation du virus
est le maintien d'une activité
économique et social le choix qu'il a
faits impliquent que la réduction la
circulation du virus sera plus faible
qu'au printemps et donc en aucun cas il
ne faut dire que dans 4 semaines nous
pourrons sortir complètement du
confinement
ce serait un oui c'est minimum six
semaines huit semaines de conflit quand
vous regardez les courbes et l'objectif
qu'a fixé chef de l'état qui est de
revenir à 5000 cas détectés par jour en
espérant que cette fois ci la stratégie
tc tracé isolé sera mal en heure autour
de 40 mille ou alors qu'on essaie ça
entre quarante cinquante mille et donc
probablement beaucoup plus de nouveaux
cas et bien ce qu'on regarde les courbes
ce n'est pas possible d'atteindre cet
objectif là dans un délai aux autres
pourquoi le gouvernement passe de
seulement un mois deux parce que sans
arrêt court après le virus parce que
sans arrêt il est il faut le dire dans
un arbitrage difficile entre encore une
fois l'activité économique et la santé
mais il faut comprendre qu'on ne doit
pas opposer les deux plus on laisse le
virus circule et plus les conséquences
sont dramatiques en termes sanitaires
mais plus l'économie sera aussi impactés
donc dans un cas si on laisse circuler
on perd sur les deux tableaux
dans l'autre cas c'est très dur pour
l'économie mais on protège les français
on évite des morts qui serait
extrêmement élevé sinon le gouvernement
parle beaucoup de cette acceptation
sociale
mais pour vous il faut dire la vérité
aux français en disant attendait ça va
durer encore six mois donc là on fait
quatre semaines de confinement mais
après ce sera peint déconfinement comme
on l'a connu en mai dernier sur il faut
dire la vérité aux français parce que
l'acceptation sociale elle est liée à
quoi elle et elle est profondément liée
aux liens de confiance entre un peuple
et ses gouvernants et quand vous ne
dites pas la vérité au peuple aux
français et bien après ne vous croient
plus et il n'y a plus d' acceptation ni
sociale ni politique mais contient 12 us
qui sont composites à ceux qui seraient
tentés de ne pas respecter ces
restrictions aujourd'hui ah mais vous
savez l'individualisme est une valeur
solidement ancrée malheureusement dans
notre société ne pas respecter une
mesure qui est fait pour nous protéger
collectivement et protéger les plus
vulnérables d'entre nous parce que c'est
pas à votre âge quand en bonne santé
qu'on va décéder du coc vide mais ce
sont les plus âgés ce sont ceux qui ont
des maladies chroniques
ce sont ceux qui sont vulnérables refusé
d'appliquer ces mesures s'est refusé de
leur accorder notre protecteur en
quelques mots vous êtes sénateur vous
êtes aussi médecin qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète le plus aussi en tant que comme
de gauche la question sociale la
question sanitaire aujourd'hui mais les
deux sont liés et les trois sont liées
parce que c'est lié à la question
économique mais nous avons un pays qui
est en grande souffrance et ce qui
m'inquiète peut-être c'est cette
incapacité du gouvernement à se projeter
suffisamment loin dans l'avenir et donc
à donner de l'espoir parce que c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas rester dans cette
situation ou sans arrêt on après sur la
tête des gens une épidémie on y fait
face ensemble ou sinon on y fait très
mal face on va continuer à berner je
mets à parler de la situation sanitaire
le sénat examine la prorogation de
l'état d'urgence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raccourcir la durée de l'état d'urgence
limiter le recours aux ordonnances
telles sont quelques-unes des exigences
du sida pour proroger le régime
d'exception souhaité par le gouvernement
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
on fait le point avec pierre henri
holderbaum regarder le sénat et le
gouvernement n'ont pas vraiment la même
vision du rpt confinement
le principal point de désaccord et la
fermeture des commerces non essentiels
annoncé par emmanuel macron pour sauver
les commerces de proximité
les sénateurs ont autorisé les préfets à
rouvrir les magasins si la situation
sanitaire s'améliore sauf que les
préfets dans les départements sont quand
même les mieux placés me semble-t-il
c'est d'ailleurs eux sans doute qui
informeront le premier minis le
président de la république pour dire si
dans telle ou telle zone du territoire
comme nous avons pu connaître au
printemps des assouplissements peuvent
être décidées donc encore une fois
soyons au plus près du terrain
permettons à nos concitoyens de respirer
aux commerçants par ailleurs aussi de
survivre il s'agit même plus de respirer
autre point de divergence le contrôle du
parlement sur la durée de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
pour prolonger ce dispositif d'exception
delà du 31 janvier le gouvernement devra
revenir devant les parlementaires
cette exigence est une exigence
fondamentale et le gouvernement je pense
c'est de l'intérêt de la démocratie
qu'ils l'acceptent parce que sinon il va
agir seul autant qu'il le voudra dans
l'exercice de pouvoirs spéciaux dont
nous ne voulons pas qu'ils puissent
abuser
les sénateurs se sont montrés
intraitables sur une éventuelle
prolongation du confinement dans un mois
puisque vous avez décidé le confinement
et que là on franchit un palier dans les
restrictions aux libertés des français
sur le point particulier du confinement
il ne puisse pas être prolongé au-delà
du 8 décembre
sans un vote pour permettre la tenue des
élections départementales et régionales
en mars prochain
le sénat facilite les votes par
procuration et les votes par
correspondance et encourage le
gouvernement augmenter le nombre de
bureaux lors du scrutin
bernard jomier accepter une limitation
des droits du parlement pendant cette
période de crise c'est indispensable
non absolument pas absolument pas et ça
cette attitude du gouvernement qui est
d'un côté d'appeler sans cesse à l'union
nationale de dire on doit faire face
tous ensemble on doit être tous ensemble
et et d'un autre côté de prendre les
décisions tout seul de marcher sur la
tête du parlement mais des instances de
santé publique aussi de la conférence
nationale de santé donc de tous les
corps élus du pays est inquiétante
on a appris quand même cette semaine que
l'ancien premier ministre avait commandé
un rapport sur la gestion de la crise va
dans le canard enchaîné
voilà on apprend ça dans la presse
satirique et que j'amène en informer le
parlement et jamais il n'a pensé à nous
donner ce rapport qui contient qui
contient vers des éléments pointant des
dysfonctionnements profond de l'état
bernard genier on voit quand même le
premier ministre était hier toute la
journée à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat vous auditionné dans le cadre de
la commission denquête ici au sénat mais
aussi à l'assemblée edouard philippe
jean castex la semaine prochaine ya des
séances de questions au gouvernement
toutes les semaines on a quand même
l'impression que les députés ils peuvent
poser des questions au gouvernement ils
ont quand même ils le voient quasiment
tous les jours les députés comme les
sénateurs exercent leurs prérogatives
la commission denquête est strictement
une prérogative parlementaire à laquelle
les membres de l'exécutif ne peuvent pas
légalement se soustraire dons qu'ils y
sont contraints mais dans le même temps
où ils viennent en commission denquête
ils posent des actes dont ils ne nous
informe pas donc ça ça dénote une
volonté de ne pas être franc avec le
parlement quand le ministre de la santé
vient et nous dit sicilia 14 mai lit en
réanimation mais qu'en fait il n'ya pas
quatorze mille lits de réanimation et
que d'ailleurs dans des médias il dit
autre chose ça montre le niveau de
respect pour le parlement de même très
franchement si vous étiez au pouvoir
est-ce que vous iriez devant le
parlement pour avoir une validation a
priori des mesures que vous prenez
contre cette crise très franchement
bernard je me sens plus timide de la
santé aujourd'hui très franchement
d'abord j'aurais demandé et je
solliciterai
l'instance qui existe le haut conseil de
santé publique la haute autorité de
santé sur la politique à mener l jeunes
en créerait pas de nouvelles explique à
ma botte
voilà j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le
conseil scientifique pour que la côte et
ses travers beaucoup ont dit les
scientifiques ont pris le pouvoir en
france et ceux qui décident tout
maintenant le politique s'efface
complètement
on a entendu beaucoup ce reproche la
crise sanitaire un virus qui a pris le
pouvoir
c'est un virus et on ne négocie pas avec
un virus donc ce n'est pas les
scientifiques nous à feu sont face à une
épidémie et nous devons avoir une
réponse qui corresponde à la réalité
scientifique on vit pas dans un monde
virtuel les personnes qui meurent dans
nos hôpitaux
elle meurt vraiment et donc c'est à ça
qu'on est astreint mais évidemment que
moi je pense qu'il fallait activer les
instances qui existent en santé publique
et il fallait porter la rallier étaient
des faits devant le parlement et le
parlement dit oui oui dit non mais vous
voyez bien que alors que le gouvernement
est très mal traitant avec le parlement
pour ma part j'ai tout de même voté oui
par souci de responsabilité aux
nouvelles mesures sanitaires le sésame
responsable pour deux
le sénat veut réduire dans le temps le
régime de cet état d'urgence sanitaire
où placer le curseur
c'est une bonne question et la réponse
elle est très difficile je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas il faut certainement pas
autoriser le gouvernement a dit à medel
aeternam pardon à maintenir un
dispositif d'exception donc il faut une
clause de revoyure reynders au 16
février
mais vous avez bien compris qu'à travers
cette question et tester la volonté du
gouvernement de réellement discuté avec
le parlement il ya un aspect très
pratique des choses le ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand le dit aux députés
et aux sénateurs
c'est qu'une navette parlementaire ça
prend du temps en commission dans chaque
chambre
on peut pas se réunir toutes les six
semaines pour dire ah et on y va encore
pendant un mois d'état d'urgence
est ce que vous comprenez quand même cet
argument un petit peu pratique
est ce que la vie parlementaire empêche
le gouvernement de prendre les mesures
nécessaires contre l'épidémie est ce que
la vie parlementaire a empêché le
gouvernement
moment d'appliquer correctement la
stratégie tester tracé isolé est ce que
le parlement a empêché le gouvernement
au mois de septembre de prendre des
vraies mesures au lieu de répondre aux
alarmes sérieuse qui avait été sonné par
une seule mesure la réduction de 14 à
sept jours de la durée d'isolement la
réponse elle est claire c'est non
le sénat souhaite aussi sécurisés sains
selon ses termes les élections
départementales et régionales prévues au
mois de mars prochain
penser qu'elles peuvent se tenir ces
élections au mois de mars non et c'est
très clair je fais partie des personnes
et le président de mon groupe l'a
exprimé d'ailleurs publiquement nous
demandons pour protéger la santé des
français
le report de ces élections au mois de
juin mais mais mais nous n'accepterons
pas un report pour des raisons
politiciennes
c'est à dire après la présidentielle le
report pour protéger la santé
mais ici on est encore en pleine
d'à-propos chose en juin prochain ce
sera peut-être encore en pleine épidémie
aura pas forcément ni très bien le sera
toujours temps au mois de mars ou
d'avril de dire ce n'est pas raisonnable
nous ne pouvons pas voter mais à ce
stade sa part est une hypothèse tout de
même tout à fait raisonnable que de
fixer les élections au mois de juin je
rappelle que le second tour des
élections municipales s'est tenue fin
juin et qu'il n'y avait pas de
circulation active du virus à ce moment
là les américains sont en train de voter
pour élire un président en pleine
épidémie
comment vous expliquez ça elle coupa
panne ou voter par correspondance par
exemple alors les américains ont des
modalités de votre bien différente
ils ne votent pas tous le même jour et
or c'est marquant de constater que dans
certains états on nage déjà autant de
votants que aux précédentes élections le
jour du vote et ils peuvent voter par
correspondance et moi je souhaite que le
vote par correspondance soit facilitée
et que le vote par procuration soit
également faciliter ce sera le mot de la
fin merci beaucoup et bernard jomier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
elsa on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]